i'm a veteran
the horse is a veteran
and i can't think of a better place that
he would be than under my care
this horse quincy is part of an elite
squad of horses in the military
they're called the caisson horses of the
old guard
they participate in full honors funerals
at arlington national cemetery
over the course of their service each
horse walks in thousands of funerals
when horses retire they need a place to
go
so the old guard has introduced the
caisson adoption project to ensure each
horse is given to their perfect forever
home to enjoy their well-earned
retirement
and that's where george comes in today
he's taking quincy home
we're a very patriotic family
the flag flies on the farm every day
and it just became a unique opportunity
for another veteran to retire on the
farm
this is a long process
they're federal property that's why they
spend so much time on making a decision
to ensure that these houses will be
taken care of for their life span
i found out through my daughter that the
horse had some health problems and what
they call navicular disease which is
nerve damage on their hoof
and the farm is a rehab farm for horses
with foot problems and many medical
problems she thought it would be an
ideal place for the horse to come and
live
he has his dog tagged just like he did
when he was in the service on his halter
only that the dog tag now reads retired
veteran
quincy will spend the rest of his life
on the farm as my companion
and
as long as he has a quality of life he
will live on the farm
forever
you